“Okay, okay, just hear me out: what if we
shot it into the sun?”
Foster asked excitedly.
“You are aware just how far away the sun
actually is, right?”
his fellow researcher Rees replied, sighing
with exhaustion at their lengthy conversation;
they had been discussing this for so long
that the food on both their trays had already
gone unappetizingly cold.
“Obviously, but think about it: we’d be
sending it into a perpetually-burning nuclear
furnace.
There’s no way it would be able to survive,”
Researcher Foster rebutted, standing by his
latest hare-brained theory.
“We send it up in a rocket, fully automated,
so no personnel have to put themselves in
harm’s way and sacrifice their lives.
Then boom, it flies into the sun.
Problem solved.
“So, it never occurred to you that 682 might
figure out a way to escape on the hundred-and
fifty-million-kilometer journey?”
Rees poked at his mashed potatoes with a fork
out of boredom.
“You’re forgetting how intelligent the
thing is; it might be an omnicidal killing
machine, but it’s smart as either of us…
well, one of us, at least.”
Sitting opposite each other in the mess hall,
Researcher Foster and Researcher Rees kept
up their bickering, debating on what would
be the best way to neutralize SCP-682, the
infamous Hard to Destroy Reptile.
It was a discussion nearly every member of
Foundation personnel had been a part of at
least once: how could they kill this unkillable
beast?
What other anomalies were they yet to try
and use against it?
Even after countless tests – most leading
to numerous containment breaches and significant
loss of life – the Foundation seemed to
be no closer to putting a definitive end to
SCP-682.
But while Rees and Foster debated more and
more outlandish possibilities, someone was
sitting nearby, listening in on every word.
At a table all by himself in the mess hall,
a man in typical Foundation Security Officer
garb was quietly scrawling everything the
pair of researchers were saying on a notepad.
The photo identification and nametag he wore
on his uniform identified him as one Elias
Anderson, a long-serving member of the SCP
Foundation, with an extensive service record
logged in their personnel database.
Of course, that name and the whole identity
were just a cover.
The real Officer Elias Anderson was dead,
his body being kept on ice, hidden in a morgue
within a secure black site.
It hadn’t taken long for the man now wearing
Anderson’s uniform and using his name to
‘update’ the officer’s photo with one
of his own face in the Foundation’s database,
keeping his subterfuge so far undetected.
Gathering up his notepad, casually hiding
it under his tray as he stood up and walked
towards the mess hall exit, the unknown infiltrator
made his way to the nearest elevator.
Riding it up to the highest level, making
sure any other passengers had gotten out at
other floors, the ‘Security Officer’ flipped
the emergency stop switch.
He reached into his pocket, retrieving a jury-rigged
handheld communication device, and began sending
a message on a secure channel.
“Agent Paratos checking in,” he wrote.
“The SCP Foundation is still bickering amongst
themselves about the best way to eliminate
the target.
SCP-682 remains contained, but alive.
Advise best course of action?”
The cursor on screen blinked for a few seconds,
awaiting a response.
“Excellent work, Agent,” the reply from
GOC Command finally arrived, lines of text
scrolling rapidly across the screen.
“As long as this anomaly is allowed to live,
it poses an ever-present threat to all life
on Earth.
What is your assessment of the Foundation’s
approach to termination?”
Paratos thought to himself for a moment, before
sending back:
“They’re overthinking it.”
“Affirmative,” the Coalition wrote.
“Have the O5 Council still denied termination
of SCP-682 via nuclear weapons?”
The undercover agent quickly responded, confirming
this was indeed still the case.
There was another pause, almost like the whole
GOC was thinking carefully about what to do
next.
“Global Occult Coalition executives have
conferred in private to authorize a Hammer
Down operation to eliminate the anomaly known
as SCP-682,” came the follow-up from Command.
“An F-22 Raptor fitted with a sixty megaton
payload will be launched at 0600, bound for
the following coordinates.”
A map reference quickly followed; the longitude
and latitude of a largely empty area of the
Pacific Ocean.
“Agent Paratos, your new objective is to
lure the creature into the open, by any means
necessary.
GOC out.”
Slipping the communicator back into his pocket,
Paratos unclicked the elevator’s stop switch,
and pressed one of the numbered floor buttons.
He already knew which one would take him back
down to SCP-682’s containment cell, and
what to do when he got there…
The commotion was unlike anything Paratos
had ever seen before; alarms were blaring
so loud that the sound was ringing in his
ears.
Most of the Research staff were fleeing for
their lives, while heavily armed Mobile Task
Force operatives in tactical gear were moving
in formation to support the security personnel.
Some had abandoned their posts out of sheer
terror, desperately looking for anywhere they
could hide in order to stay alive.
Under the ear-splitting wail of alerts was
a cacophony of chaos, a mix of hailing gunfire
from the MTF’s weapons, the crumble of walls
as the facility around them was being torn
apart, and the angered, vicious roars of the
rampaging reptile.
All hands were on deck, the Foundation – while
always on high alert – had been caught completely
unprepared for a containment breach.
SCP-682 was making short work of any living
personnel in its path, carving them up with
its claws or devouring them while they were
still alive, laving a trail of blood and destruction
in its wake.
Any survivors on site were quickly instructed
to retreat into the Command Centre, and Paratos
casually slid in alongside a gaggle of panicking
researchers.
He recognized one from the mess hall; Researcher
Foster, wide-eyed and disassociating in shock,
the blood of his colleague Rees still wet
on his face and lab coat.
The outer doors of the Command Center were
locked down, while all efforts inside were
put towards coordinating the re-containment
effort, tracking the escaped anomaly’s movements
via a live satellite feed.
Agent Paratos had to think and act fast.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile was already making
its way towards water, where GOC fighter jets
would enrage it in order to make the anomaly
follow them to the target area.
But if the Foundation had a chance to recapture
SCP-682, his entire mission would be declared
a failure.
Checking that nobody was watching, Paratos
snuck over to a computer terminal.
Looking underneath, he located a panel and
unscrewed it as quickly and inconspicuously
as he could.
Reaching for his communicator, he pulled the
device into one of the ports underneath the
terminal, and it instantly went to work, installing
proprietary software that would block any
outbound Foundation communication.
“H-hey!”
Foster stammered, spotting Paratos sabotaging
the terminal.
“Hey, hey!
What’s he doing?”
Within moments, the researcher had gained
the attention of the surviving security personnel,
who rushed over and tackled the saboteur.
The officers restrained Paratos, one grabbing
each of his arms as they held him in place.
But it was too late.
Communications suddenly went offline, cutting
the Command Center off from the rest of the
Foundation outside.
“Who are you?” one of the security guards
yelled over and over again, punching the infiltrator
in the gut each time.
“Who do you work for?”
Fighting through the pain, Paratos had kept
his jaw clenched so tightly that he could
feel his teeth grinding together, like they
were about to crack.
“We still have access to all saved internal
data,” one of the Foundation technicians
– a man named Baxter – chimed in after
examining the computer terminal.
“According to this security footage, he’s
the one who sprung 682.”
“D-do we still have no comms?”
Foster asked timidly, still trying to wipe
Rees’ blood off his coat.
“Negative,” the technician answered.
“Whatever that device is, it’s deactivated
every way we have to transmit… we can still
receive, though.”
His voice trailed off, reducing to match the
low silence that was now filling the Command
Centre.
Everyone in the room, including the restrained
Agent Paratos, had gradually turned to face
the massive screens, displaying the satellite
footage of SCP-682.
It was small, but visible thanks to how zoomed
in the orbital lens was.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile had reached the
water, and was making its way across the ocean.
At the same time, the bird’s eye feed of
the Pacific showed something else, a tiny,
winged object barrelling through the air at
almost supersonic speeds.
“That’s a fighter jet,” one of the security
guards declared, breaking the tense silence.
“Probably a Raptor by the look of it.”
It was, in fact, a fighter jet speeding towards
SCP-682.
The creature seemed unaware of the aircraft,
it was merely traveling in the opposite direction,
but the pair were on a direct course with
each other, bound to meet at any moment now…
Something ejected from the F-22 the exact
moment it passed over the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, followed almost instantly by a bright
flash of light.
A huge explosion engulfed the area of the
ocean where the creature had been, a ball
of radioactive fire in the middle of the water.
The Foundation personnel in the Command Center
watched in horror at the nuclear detonation,
holding their breath, dreading what they would
see when the mushroom cloud dissipated.
“He’s with the Coalition,” the nearest
security guard realized, referring to Paratos.
It was well known among staff that the SCP
Foundation maintained a somewhat fragile alliance
with the Global Occult Coalition.
While they had historically worked together
when their goals aligned, the GOC were more
intent on destroying anomalies wholesale,
wiping them from existence in order to protect
the United Nations and peoples of the world.
The Foundation, on the other hand, although
never afraid to get their hands dirty, but
more of an emphasis on containment and study
of anomalies, rather than outright extermination.
“What the hell have you done, you maniac?”
yelled one of the doctors trapped in the Command
Centre.
“That monstrosity needed to be eliminated,”
Paratos argued back.
“While you were wasting time keeping it
submerged in acid, ready to break out again
and start slaughtering people, we acted.
And look for yourselves, it worked.
You should be thanking the GOC and me, because
it turns out SCP-682 wasn’t invincible after
all.”
“No, it-it isn’t,” Foster spoke up.
“Rees and I were talking about it earlier,
he said SCP-682’s greatest strength isn’t
being invulnerable.
It’s being adaptable.
It can change itself, mutate in response to
damage, or in order to survive a hostile environment.
And you just… you haven’t killed it.
You’ve allowed it to adapt to nukes.”
On the screens, something burst from underneath
the water.
The overhead view from the satellite feed
filled the display an image of a dark, rocky
surface.
“Who zoomed in on the feed?
Pull it back!”
Baxter announced, trying to hide what they
were all afraid of: that the footage it wasn’t
zoomed in at all; it was just looking at something
much bigger now.
As the camera zoomed out, increasing its field
of view, what looked like a dark surface on
screen now looked to be a huge mass of scales.
The satellite feed pulled further back, revealing
the full extent of what was now standing in
the Pacific Ocean: it was SCP-682, not only
still alive, but much, much bigger than before.
The creature had adapted to the intense heat
of the nuclear payload that had been dropped
on it, soaking up the bomb’s radiation and
using it as a way to increase its body mass
several million times over.
“Uhh, it looks like we have a…”
Baxter said dumbfounded, eyes widened in horror,
“A kaiju on our hands.”
Paratos stared up at the screen, looking at
the monstrous Reptile now so much bigger than
before.
Even from the satellite’s current overhead
angle, SCP-682 looked like it could now tower
over most buildings, save for maybe exceptionally
tall skyscrapers.
What’s more, the creature was thrashing
and roaring in the ocean, entering an enraged
state now infinitely more devasting thanks
to its newfound size… and it was all Paratos’
fault.
“Hey!”
Foster yelled at the restrained GOC operative.
“We need to get the word out, and the rest
of this facility is still on lockdown.
Whatever you did to disable communications,
reverse it.”
“What good will that do?”
Paratos asked in a blind panic.
“Look at the size of that abomination now.
It’ll wipe us all out.
Oh god, what have I done?”
The agent was shocked into silence by a sudden
slap; the timid Researcher Foster had struck
him sharply across the face.
“Cry about it later, this is on you, but
do you want to be part of the solution or
keep being part of the problem?”
Foster yelled, gripping Paratos by the collar.
“I…
I can’t reverse it,” he replied.
“I blocked all outbound Foundation transmissions.
My comm device is the only thing that wasn’t
affected.”
“Good enough,” Foster said, holding a
hand out to Baxter who passed him the confiscated
GOC tech.
“Then you’re going to contact the Coalition
for us.”
“What for?”
“The Foundation has a joint project we’ve
been working on with them and Hy-Brasil for
just this sort of occasion,” the researcher
stated, holding out the device to Agent Paratos
as the security finally released his arms.
“If there was ever a time we needed it,
it’s now.”
“Wait, you mean…”
Paratos finally realized what Foster meant.
“You’re talking about the Dragonslayer,
aren’t you?”
The next hour flew by.
Time seemed to be moving faster, as the newly
mutated SCP-682 swam through the waters of
the Pacific.
It was traveling in a northwest direction;
the collection of Foundation personnel still
locked in the Command Center having projected
that it was heading for the nearest landmass,
which meant it would reach Hawaii any moment.
Throughout that entire time, Foster, Paratos,
and Baxter were sending urgent communiques
to the Global Occult Coalition, trying to
get them to cooperate and engage in contact
with the wider SCP Foundation beyond the facility
they were currently stuck in.
Not one of them knew which was harder, trying
to kill an unkillable lizard that had absorbed
a nuclear blast, or trying to force the GOC
and Foundation to work together without arguing
over whose fault this whole mess was.
All the while, the towering, monstrous reptilian
form of SCP-682 was getting closer and closer
to its destination…
Drawing itself up to its full, enlarged height,
SCP-682 roared, large enough to block out
sunlight and cast an ominous shadow over the
Hawaiian coastline.
Onlookers watched in terror as the Hard to
Destroy Reptile rose from the water, bearing
down on their shores with the intent to slaughter
every living thing on the island.
Then, just as SCP-682 neared the landmass,
the creature paused.
It could hear something getting closer, getting
louder as it approached from behind – no,
above – and with it came the sound of…
someone reciting poetry?
Before the creature could turn to face its
attacker, the piercing metal of the Cold Iron
Sword plunged through its scaly back and out
through its front.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile roared at the
searing pain of the stab wound, whipping its
tail as it thrashed in its fury.
Something heavy and metallic deflected a swipe
of the creature’s tail; it was the huge,
robotic arm of a gigantic mechanized titan.
It was SCP-5514, the Dragonslayer.
Controlled by its skilled pilots, with a swift,
fluid motion, SCP-5514 delivered a brutal
backhanded strike to the Reptile’s snout,
staggering the beast while also withdrawing
its mighty Cold Iron Sword at the same time.
SCP-682 growled in discontent; even its infamously
adaptable healing abilities were halted by
a wound from the Dragonslayer’s blade.
Watched by the innocent civilians on the island,
and the Foundation through their satellite
above, the kaiju-killing mech assumed a battle-ready
stance, as the Hard to Destroy Reptile reeled
back to roar.
The moment it opened its sharp-toothed jaws,
a fiery atomic blast came spewing forth from
SCP-682.
It had adapted not only to withstand the nuclear
weapon the GOC had used on it, but also developed
the ability to unleash a burst of radioactive
fire.
Within the Dragonslayer, the pilots braced
for impact as the blast struck the outer armor
of the mech.
Thankfully, through the conceptual engineering
used when building it, SCP-5514 was welded
to the Earth itself, as well as the very concept
of humanity’s resilience.
That gave it just enough protection against
the onslaught of SCP-682’s newfound ability.
Holding up one arm to defend itself, the Dragonslayer
reached upwards for its Rounded Recoiling
Plasma – the disc it wore as a hat – with
its free hand.
With a spin, it flung the razor-edged weapon
at SCP-682 like a frisbee.
It collided with the Hard to Destroy Reptile,
still unleashing its nuclear fire-breath,
and staggered the crocodilian creature for
just a moment, causing its blast to stop.
SCP-5514’s commanded the mech to charge
forward as the Rounded Recoiling Plasma disc
spun back through the air and returned to
the Dragonslayer’s hand thanks to its built-in
electromagnets.
Within the robotic vehicle, the Thousand Word
Arrows were still loudly reciting their poetry.
The mech’s strangest weapon was a group
of seven poets who would rhyme and chant about
the death and defeat of the large-scale monsters
SCP-5514 was designed to fight.
Their voices were being blared out of the
Dragonslayer at a loud enough volume to enrage
SCP-682 further.
It roared again, and then started rushing
towards its adversary, the pair of colossal
combatants seemingly charging into a head-on
collision.
As it placed one mechanical foot before the
other, huge splashes erupting as its feet
impacted the surface of the ocean, the Dragonslayer
opened fire.
The Beowulf-Sigured Railgun mounted on its
shoulder began launching electromagnetic energy
bolts at SCP-682.
The weapon used anomalously altered gravity
to blast its targets.
With each hit, the energy projectiles seared
through the outer scales of the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, while making the towering creature
dramatically heavier.
Each projectile impacted at super terminal
velocities, making SCP-682’s already enlarged
body feel heavier and slower with every hit.
Each step it took seemed to sink deeper under
the ocean, waves lapping at the Reptile’s
damaged scales, sea salt washing over its
gaping wounds.
By the time it was about to clash with the
Dragonslayer, the Hard to Destroy Reptile
felt such huge forces of additional weight
acting on it that its whole body was being
pushed further and further below water level,
feet sinking heavily into the seafloor below.
Still standing upright, SCP-5514 raised its
Cold Iron Sword and brought it down in one
fell swipe, cleaving the creature’s head
from its shoulders, before wasting no time
slicing up what was left of its nuclear-enlarged
body.
Before long, an area of the Pacific Ocean
was red with SCP-682’s blood.
Victorious for now, the Dragonslayer began
gathering up the remains of the Hard to Destroy
Reptile before it had a chance to reform its
body.
From the Command Center, the Foundation personnel
cheered and whooped excitedly.
Even Agent Paratos found himself overwhelmed
with relief.
Although he’d been sent with the intention
of assisting them in killing the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, the mission that the GOC had sent
him on had only made the creature more of
a threat.
For now, at least, it was defeated, although
Paratos’ celebration of that fact was cut
short when one of the Foundation doctors tapped
him on the shoulder.
“Excuse me, GOC Agent Paratos, isn’t it?”
the man asked.
“My name is Doctor Bright, and this here
is my associate Doctor Clef.
We’d like to have a word with you about
the ‘incident’ you just caused…”
Now go and check out “SCP-682 CRAZIEST MUTATIONS
AND ADAPTATIONS” and “SCP-682 WAYS THE
SCP FOUNDATION TRIED TO KILL HARD TO DESTROY
REPTILE” to see some of the extreme lengths
the Foundation has gone to in their attempts
to kill SCP-682!